but just as I promised in 2016 I am your  voice I am your voice  oh man I am so excited the Washington  establishment wants to silence us but we  will not let them do that  what we have built together over the  past six years is the greatest movement  in history because it is not about  politics it's about our love for this  great country America and we're not  going to let it fail  I am running because I believe the world  has not yet seen the True Glory of what  this nation can be we have not reached  that Pinnacle believe it or not  in fact we can go very far we're going  to have to go far first we have to get  out of this ditch and once we're out  you'll see things that nobody imagined  for any country